[Music]
Hello everyone. Uh, thanks Rick and the
whole AI engineer conference team for
putting this together and having me. I
am Will Brown. I am a machine learning
researcher at Morgan Stanley. And today
I want to talk to you all a bit about
what I think reinforcement learning or
RL means for agents. So I was in grad
school at Columbia for a while and I
mostly worked on theory for multi-agent
reinforcement learning and over the past
couple years I have been working at
Morgan Stanley on a wide range of LM
related projects some of which look kind
of like agents but I will not really be
talking too much about that today. Uh
I'm also relatively active on X the
everything app and that will become
relevant later in the talk. This talk I
think will be probably a little
different from most of the talks at the
conference. Um it's not about things we
ship to prod. It's not about things that
definitely work and you should go do
tomorrow that are like proven science or
best practices. It's about where we
might be headed. And I want to really
just tell a story that will synthesize
some things that have been happening in
the broader research community um and uh
where these trends might be pointing, do
some speculation, and also talk about
some uh recent open source work of my
own. Um, and the goal of this is to help
you plan and understand what
reinforcement learning means, what it
means for agents, and how to best be
ready for a potential future, which may
involve reinforcement learning as part
of the agent engineering
loop. So, um, where are we today? Most
LLMs that we work with are essentially
chatbots. I think it's helpful to think
about OpenAI's, uh, five levels
framework here. So, we did pretty well
with chatbots. Seems like we're doing
pretty well with reasoners. Um, these
are great models for question answer.
They're very helpful for interactive
problem solving. We have the 01, 03, R1,
Gro 3, Gemini, etc. models that are
really good at kind of thinking longer.
Um, and we're trying to figure out how
we take all of this and make agents
level three. Um, and these are systems
that are taking actions. These are
systems that are doing things that are
longer and harder and more complex. And
currently the way we tend to do this is
chaining together multiple calls to
these underlying chatbot or reasoner
LLM. And we do lots of things like
prompt engineering, tool calling, eval
giving the models tools of their own to
use, having humans in the loop. And the
results are like pretty good. Um,
there's a lot of things that we can do
and then there's a lot of stuff that it
feels like is around the corner that
we're all imagining about AGI, but we're
not really to the point yet where these
things are going off and doing the
things that we would imagine an AGI is
really doing to the degree of autonomy
that that would, I presume, entail. So,
I think it's useful a bit to distinguish
between agents and pipelines. I think
Barry's talk earlier was a good way to
kind of frame this. I'm going to use
pipelines to encapsulate what Barry
called workflows. Um, and I think these
are really systems with fairly low
degrees of autonomy. And there's a very
non-trivial non-trivial amount of
engineering required to determine these
decision trees to say how does one
action or call flow into another? How uh
to another? How do we refine the
prompts? Um, and it seems like a lot of
the winning apps in the agent space have
very tight feedback loops. And so
whether or not you want to call these
agents or pipelines, these are things
where a user is interacting with some
sort of interface. They're telling it
what to do. The thing will do some stuff
and come back relatively quickly. Things
like the idees like cursor, wind, surf,
and replet um and search tools that are
really good at harder question answer
maybe with some web search or research
integrated. But there's not that many
agents nowadays that will go off and
like do stuff for more than 10 minutes
at a time. I think Devon, Operator, and
OpenAI's deep research are the three
that really come to mind as like feeling
a little more in the like autonomous
agent direction. And I think a lot of us
might be wondering how do we make more
of these? And the kind of traditional
wisdom is like okay, we'll just wait for
better models. Once better models are
around, we can just like use those,
we'll be good. But I think it's also to
kind of take note of like the
traditional definition of reinforcement
learning and what an agent means there,
which is this idea of a thing that is
interacting with an environment with a
goal. And the goal of that and the
system is designed to learn how to get
better at that goal over time via
repeated interaction uh with the system.
And I think this is something that a lot
of us are either doing manually or don't
really have the tools to do, which is
once we have our thing that it's set up
to make the calls we want and the
performance is like 70%. And we've done
a lot of prompt tuning and we want to
get it up to 90% but we just like don't
have the models to do it or the models
struggle to get the success. What's our
path forward? Um, and so in terms of
model trends, I think I won't spend too
much time talking about this, but uh
pre-training seems to be having
diminishing returns to capital at least.
We're still seeing kind of like loss go
down, but uh it does kind of feel like
we need new tricks. Um reinforcement
learning from human feedback is great
for making kind of friendly chat bots.
Um but it doesn't really seem to uh be
continually pushing us at the frontier
of smarter and smarter and smarter
models. uh we talk a lot about synthetic
data and I think synthetic data is great
for distilling uh larger models down
into smaller models to have kind of
really tiny models that are really
performant but on its own it doesn't
seem to be an unlock for like massive
capabilities uh getting better and
better unless we throw in verification
in the loop or rejection sampling or any
of these things and that really takes us
to the world of reinforcement learning
where this seems to be the trick that
unlocked test time scaling for 01 models
in R1 um it's not bottlenecked by
needing manually curated human data and
it does seem to actually work. Um, I
think we all kind of took note about a
month ago when DeepSeek released the R1
model and paper to the world and I think
this was really exciting because it was
the first paper that really explained
how you build a thing like 01. We'd had
kind of speculation and some rumors, but
they really laid out the algorithm and
the mechanisms for what it takes to get
a model to learn to do this kind of
reasoning. And it turns out it was
essentially just reinforcement learning
where you give the model some questions,
you measure if it's getting the answer
right, and you just kind of turn this
crank of giving it feedback to do more
like the things that worked well and
less like the things that didn't work.
Um, and what you end up seeing is that
the the long chain of thought from
models like 01 and R1 actually emerges
as a byproduct of this. It wasn't kind
of manually programmed in where the
models were like given data of like
10,000 token reasoning steps. this was a
thing the model learned to do because it
was a good strategy and reinforcement
learning at the core is really about
identifying good strategies for solving
problems. Um it also seems like open
source models are are back in a big way.
There's a lot of excitement around the
open source community. Um people have
been working on replication efforts for
the 01 project um and have also been
trying to distill data from 01 down into
smaller models. And so what next? How
does this relate to agents? Um I think
it'll be helpful to know a little bit
about how reinforcement learning works.
The key idea is to explore and exploit.
So you want to try stuff, see what
works, do more of the things that
worked, less of the things that didn't.
And so in this feedback loop um
demonstrated here in the image, we can
see a ch a challenge where a model is uh
supposed to be writing code to pass test
cases and we give it rewards that
correspond to things like formatting
using the right language and then
ultimately whether or not the test cases
are passing. And so this is kind of a
numerical signal that rather than like
training on data uh where we are kind of
curating this in advance, we are letting
the model do synthetic data rollouts and
seeing scores from these rollouts which
then are fed back into the model. And so
the GRPO algorithm which maybe some of
you have heard about is the algorithm
DeepC used. I think it's less of like a
technical breakthrough in terms of it
being a really important new algorithm
to study, but I think it's very
conceptually simple and I think it's a
nice way to think about what
reinforcement learning means. And the
idea really is just that you for a given
prompt sample n completions. You score
them all and you tell the model be more
like the ones with higher scores. Um
this is still in kind of the single turn
reasoner model non-aggentic world. Uh
and so the challenges that lie ahead um
are going to be about how do we take
these ideas uh and extend them into uh
more powerful, more agent, more
autonomous systems. But we do know that
it can be done. So, OpenAI's deep
research still has a lot of questions
that we do not know the answers to about
how it works, but they have told us that
it was endto-end reinforcement learning.
And so, this is a case where the model
is taking up to potentially a hundred
different tool calls of browsing or
querying different parts of the internet
to synthesize a large angler. And it
does seem, I think, to many people's
vibe check opinions very impressive. Um,
but it also is like not AGI in the sense
of you can't get it to go like uh work
in a repo or like solve hard software
engineering tasks. And people have kind
of anecdotally found that it does
struggle a bit for like out of
distribution tasks or like if you wanted
to fill out a table with like a 100 very
manual calculations, it can struggle
there. And so it seems like
reinforcement learning on one hand is a
big unlock for new skills and more
autonomy, but it's not a thing that so
far has granted us agents that can just
do everything and know how to solve all
kinds of problems. But it is a path
forward for teaching a model skills and
having the model learn how to get better
at certain skills, particularly in
conjunction with environments and tools
and verification.
Um, and so there is infrastructure out
there for doing this on our own kind of.
Um, a lot of it is still RLHF style by
which I mean it's about kind of single
turn interactions where the goal is we
have reward signals that come from kind
of human data that has been combined
into a reward model. Um, and if we want
to have RL agents becoming part of our
systems, maybe we will get really good
API services from the large labs that
let us build these things and hook into
GPT whatever um or cloud whatever and
train these sorts of models on our own
with fine-tuning, but we also don't
really have these options yet. Um,
OpenAI has kind of teased their
reinforcement fine-tuning feedback, but
it's not uh multi-step tool tool calling
yet. And so I think if we want to plan
ahead, it's worth kind of noting and
asking what would this ecosystem look
like? And there's a lot of unknown
questions like how much this will cost,
how small can the models be, will it
generalize across tasks, uh and how do
we design good rewards and good
environments? And there's a lot of
opportunity here. Um open source uh
infrastructure, there's a lot of room to
build and grow and determine what the
best practices are going to be, what the
right tools will be, as well as
companies that can build tools for to
support this ecosystem. uh whether or
not they're already in the fine-tuning
world or not. Um and services for
supporting this kind of agentic RL and I
think also it is worth thinking about
things that are like not literal RL in
the sense of training the model but at
the prompt level there's all sorts of
automation we can do. So if you've used
DSPI I think that is kind of adjacent to
RL in the flavor of having a signal that
we can then uh bootstrap from to improve
our uh underlying system based on
improving some downstream scores. Um,
now I want to share a story with you
about a single Python file I wrote a
couple weeks ago. Um, so this was the
weekend after R1 came out and I'd been
reading the paper and thought it was
really cool. We had not had the Nvidia
stock crash quite yet. Um, and uh, I was
just playing around with some
experiments. I was taking the a hug a
trainer from HuggingFace that had the
GRPO algorithm and I was getting a
really small language model llama 1B to
do some reasoning and then give an
answer for math questions. And I started
with like a pretty simple system prompt
and I was just training the model to let
it see what it did. And I had kind of
manually cured some rewards in terms of
what the scoring function should look
like. And I just kind of like tweeted it
out um where I had an example of the
model kind of looking like it's doing
some selfcorrection and so showing that
the accuracy gets better as well as the
uh length of response will initially
drop once it learns to kind of follow
the format. Then it goes back up as it
learns to kind of take advantage of
longer chains of thought to do its
reasoning. And this was not the first
thing to replicate in any sense. I
wouldn't really call it a true
replication. Um it was far from the most
complicated and I think that actually
caught a lot of people's imaginations
and it became kind of a thing. Um, so
over the next two weeks after that, it
just took on a life of its own where a
lot of people were kind of tweeting
about it and forking it and making
modifications to it and making it
something you could run in a Jupyter
notebook, making it more accessible,
writing blog posts about it. And it was
interesting um because it to me didn't
feel like a thing that kind of merited
this level of excitement. But what I
think was catching people's imagination
was that it was one file of code. It was
really simple and it invited uh
modification in a very userfriendly
engaging way which I like to call rubric
engineering. And so the idea of rubric
engineering here is that similar to
prompt engineering um to have a model do
reinforcement learning it's going to get
some reward but what should this reward
be? In the most simple version it's just
like did it get the question right or
wrong like does a equal b. But there's a
lot more you can do beyond this. And so
I think the the single file of code
exposed uh examples of this where you
can give the model points for things
like following this XML structure. Like
if it gets a certain tag right you give
it plus one point. Um, if it has an
integer answer that's still the wrong
answer, but it's learned that the format
should be an integer answer. Get some
points for that. Um, and there's a lot
of room here for getting creative and
for designing rules that are not just
downstream eval to for our own sake know
whether a thing is working, but to allow
the model itself to know whether it's
working and use that as feedback for
going further and training more. Um, and
this is very early stages. There's a lot
of things we don't know and I think
there's a lot of opportunity to get
creative and explore and try things out
such as using LMS to design these
rubrics. Uh autotuning these rubrics or
autotuning your prompts with frameworks
like DSPI. Um incorporating LM judges as
part of the scoring system. And then
also I think reward hacking is an issue
to be very cautious of where the idea is
you want to ensure that the the reward
model you're using is actually capturing
the goal and it doesn't have kind of
these back doors where a model can kind
of cheat and do something else that
ultimately results in it kind of getting
a super high reward without learning to
do the actual task. Um, and following
this, I have been trying to learn from
those lessons of what I saw people using
out in the wild and make something that
is a little more uh robust and uh usable
for actual projects beyond just one file
of code. Um, and this has been a kind of
very recent effort. It's not a thing
that I'm telling you to go use for all
your problems tomorrow, but I think it's
my attempt doing some open- source uh
research code um that will help people
potentially try these things out easier
and answer some questions uh about this.
And so what this really is, it's a a
framework for doing RL inside of
multi-step environments. So the idea
here is that lots of us have built these
great agent frameworks for using API
models. And the hope would be that we
can leverage those existing environments
and uh frameworks to uh h actually do
RL. So here the idea is you can just
create this environment thing that the
model plugs into and you don't have to
worry about the weights or the tokens.
you can just write an interaction
protocol and then this gets fed into a
trainer and so once you build this
environment you can just kind of let it
run and uh have a model that once you
give it some rewards learns to get
better and better over time. Um and to
conclude I want to talk about what I
think AI engineering might look like in
the RL era. So this is all still
something that is very new. Uh, we don't
know whether the off-the-shelf API
models are going to just work for the
tasks we throw at them. It might be the
case that they do. It might be the case
that they don't. Um, one reason I think
that they might not be the entire
solution is that it is really hard to
include a skill in a prompt. You can
include knowledge in a prompt. Um, but a
lot of us when we try something, we
don't nail it the first time and it
takes a little bit of trial and error.
Um, and it seems to be the case that
models are like this as well, where a
model does get better at a thing and
really gets a skill nailed down by trial
and error. And this has been the most
promising unlock we've seen so far for
these higher autonomy agents like deep
research. Um, fine-tuning might still be
important. And I think a lot of people
wrote off fine-tuning for a while
because open models were far enough
behind the frontier that like a prompted
o uh frontier model API was just going
to beat a smaller fine-tuned model. I
think one we're now seeing the open and
closed source gap be close enough that
this is less of a concern. A lot of
people are using open source hosted
models in their platforms. Um, and also,
uh, RL, the most kind of true version of
RL that DeepS did for their R1 model
that OpenAI has talked about doing for,
uh, deep research requires doing some
reinforcement learning. Um, there's a
lot of challenges here. There's a lot of
research questions we don't know the
answers to. Um, but there's a lot of
things that I think these skills we've
learned from doing AI engineering over
the past couple years translate very
directly to, which is that the challenge
of building environments and rubrics is
not that different from the challenge of
building evals and prompts. We still
need good monitoring tools. We still
need a large ecosystem of companies and
platforms and products that support the
kinds of agents we want to build. Um, so
I think all the stuff we've been doing
is going to be essential and it's worth
looking ahead a little bit to see if we
end up in a world where we have to do a
little bit more reinforcement learning
to unlock things like true autonomous
agents or innovators or organizations
that are powered by language models. Um,
what does that look like? Uh, we will
find out.
[Music]
[Applause]